مفاجاه كبرى كشفت عنها معلومات
استخباراتيه تم جمعها من طائرات ايرانيه
مسيره اسقطت في اوكرانيا هذه المعلومات
كشفت ان غالبيه اجزاء هذه الطائرات
الايرانيه صنعت من قبل شركات في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والنمسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا وكذلك اليابان هذا الامر اثار
قلق المسؤولين والمحللين الغربيين كذلك
دفع الحكومه الامريكيه الى فتح تحقيق في
هذا الملف لكن السؤال كيف تصل هذه الاجزاء
الى ايران وهل هذا يعني ان العقوبات
المواقعه على طيران هي مجرد حبر على ورق
والى اي مدى هناك امكانيه لمنع الوصول هذه
القطعه التي تستخدمها طهران في مسيرتها
هذا الموضوع سنناقشه مع السيد ديفيد برايد
خبير الاسلحه ومؤسس معهد العلوم والامن
الدولي في واشنطن اولا مستر ديفيد اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتا يعني بالرغم من انه طيران
واحده من الدول التي يوقع عليها عقوبات
يقال انها اكثر العقوبات صرامه في العالم
لكن يبدو ان ايران تحصل علامات تريد برايك
كيف تحصل ايران على هذه القطعه التي
تستخدمها في تصنيع مسيارتها
للعقوبات وهي عرضه لعدد كبير من ضوابط
التصدير من قبل العديد من الدول المزوده
لكن هذه الضوابط هي اشبه بشبكه وليست
جدارا منيعه لذلك عمدت ايران الى شراء تلك
القطع بصوره النمطيه عبر اللجوء الى وكلاء
لشراء الاجزاء ربما عبر احد الموزعين في
بلد اخر لذلك فان قضيه حصول ايران على تلك
الاجزاء لم تلقى الاهتمام الكافيه الذي
يتعين ايلاؤه له وعندما يحدث شيء من ذلك
القدير يتم مثلا تصدير اجزاء السيارات
لانه كما ذكرنا ضوابط وقوانين التصدير هي
اشبه ما تكون بالشبكه وليست بالجدار
مستر ديفيد يعني تحدثت في السابق في انه
يجب على الحكومات والشركات ان تتعاون معا
لمنع حصول ايران على هذه القطعه لكن ما هي
الوسيله خاصه بانه الكثير من هذه القطعه
اولا غير خاضعه لضوابط التصدير ويمكن
شراءها بسهوله عبر الانترنت
المورده الرئيسيه مثل الصين اما روسيا
بطبيعه الحال ليست شريكا في هذا الشان لكن
يتعين على دول الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه سن قوانين الجديده او
تطبيق لوائح جديده تجعلوا من التزويد
باجزاء محدده مهمه من السيارات امرا غير
قانوني ويمكن انفاذ ذلك عبر طريقتين عبر
الشروع في عمليه قانونيه ضد التزويد
باجزاء لايران مع سابق العلم بذلك بصوره
مباشره او غير مباشره مع ما يترتب على ذلك
من عقوبه جنائيه وفي حال حدوث عمليه
التصدير بالمصادفه من دون
معرفهها هي ايران فيمكن تطبيق
من الحذر ويتمثل الجانب الاخر من المساله
في طلب التعاون من الشركات بحيث يتم تنسيق
مع الحكومات لتقليل فرصه وصول اجزاء
الشركات الى مسيرات ايران وفي الماضي كان
هذا النوع من التعاون مهما للغايه
للحيلوله دون تصدير البضائع الى بلد مصريه
عن ضوابط التصدير في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اعلنت انها بدات تحقيق في هذا
الملف ملف وصول قطع واجزاء غربيه من
الولايات المتحده واوروبا لاستخدامها في
صناعه مسيرات ايرانيه لكن برايك هل ستنجح
الوكاله الفيدراليه في الوصول الى نتائج
محدده
عندي حكومه الولايات المتحده برمتها قادره
للغايه على معرفه الشبكات وشبكات الاتجار
وشبكات التهريب وطريقه عملها واماكن
موضعها وهويه المتورطين وكيف انتهى المطاف
بهذه الاجزاء في ايران وحسب ما اعرفه فاذا
الشركات تبدي تعاونا لانها عرضه في
الولايات المتحده على وجه التحديد لغرامات
نظيره تزويد او بيع اجزاء تصل في نهايه
الامر الى ايران لذلك القوانين الامريكيه
صارمه للغايه واعتقد انه يمكنها التركيز
اكثر على اجزاء السيارات لكن رغم ذلك لدى
الشركات كل الدوافع التي تجعلها تتعاون مع
السلطات الفضائيه بغيه تفادي العقوبات
بموجب القوانين المعمول بها
شهدت عده حالات فريده توضح كيفيه تمكن
حكومه الولايات المتحده من تحديد الشبكات
التجار الايرانيه ناهيك عن تحديد الاشخاص
المتورطين في طهران على سبيل المثال
والشركات المنخرطه ويمكنهم البحث مباشره
عبر اجزاء من اوروبا ما اذا كان هناك عميل
ايراني في الولايات المتحده كان جلب
الاجزاء ثم شحنها بطريقه قانونيه الى
ايران فثمت العديد من الطرق المتنوعه التي
يمكن ان تنتهي عبرها هذه البضائع في ايران
ولا تزال الولايات المتحده تبذل جهدها لحل
هذه الشبكات ثم ملاحقه المتورطين فيها
مستر ديفيد تحدثت عن انه الشركات الصينيه
تساهم بشكل كبير في تزويد طهران بمثل هذه
القطعه لكن على الجانب الاخر هل برايك
تحاول الصين مساعده روسيا عن طريق وسيط
مثل ايران ام انه التعاون ما بين روسيا
ايران في مجال المسيارات بعيدا عن الصين
قد لا تتعاون الصين بشكل علني مع ايران
ابو روسيا لتوفير اجزاء المسيرات لكن
بالتاكيد يمكنها القيام باكثر من ذلك
بكثير لمنع تصدير هذه الاجزاء الى ايران
او روسيا لكن بطبيعه الحال لدى روسيا
برامجها الخاصه بالمسيرات لذلك يمكن للصين
القيام باكثر من ذلك لكنها كانت متردده
حياله القيام بذلك ويمكن للولايات المتحده
لاعبوا دور في حفل الصين على القيام بذلك
عبر تطبيق عقوبات على الشركات الصينيه
والمصارف الصينيه المنخارطه في التحويلات
الماليه ذات الصله
مستر ديفيد برايت خبير الاسلحه ومؤسس معهد
العلوم والامن الدولي شكرا جزيلا على كل
هذه التوضيحات كنت معنا من واشنطن